salut dans une précédente vidéo je vous
avais posé quelques questions pour la
série expérience mentale c'était la
deuxième collecte de données vous l'avez
ici si vous l'aviez pas vu
vous avez été 65 1535 à répondre et j'ai
enfin traiter toute cette donnée on va
voir ce qu'on peut en tirer quelque
conclusion on peut en faire et qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire de toutes ces réponses
là génériques
[Musique]
l'idée principale de ce test était de
collecter des données parfois réfléchi
parfois spontanée en demandant l'âge des
personnes pour voir les réponses qui
arrivait le plus d'une pour voir comme
dans le titre de cette vidéo si on est
des clones ou pas mais surtout pour
comprendre les automatismes de notre
cerveau dans la dernière vidéo que je
vous mets ici je vous parlais de l'effet
de ce troupeau et on a vu qu'on avait
des traitement cognitif un peu programme
et qui prenait le pas je me suis dit que
ce serait intéressant de voir avec vous
comme vous êtes nombreux si on peut en
tirer des conclusions voir quelque chose
des liens alors je le dis tout de suite
j'ai très peu tenu compte de l'âge parce
que je me suis rendu compte dans l'entré
temps les données durant un mois et demi
un mois et demi à traiter les données je
me suis pas rendu compte de l'ampleur du
travail qui avait je disais je me suis
rendu compte que l'âge n'avait pas
d'incidence quasi pas d'incidence sur
les réponses à part un endroit dans la
première question la première question
c'est est quel est votre film préféré la
tendance que j'ai vus par rapport à
l'âge c'est que plus la personne est
jeune plus son film préféré est l'un des
derniers films d'action voire de super
héros qui serait sorti dans la dernière
année
c'est quelque chose que j'avais
pressenti mois d'expérience dans la vie
courante et ça s'est confirmé largement
les films qui arrivent en tête sont
plutôt des films de garçon ou en tout
cas on aurait tendance à dire que c'est
des films de garçons parce que plein de
filles aiment ces films aussi et c'est
pas très étonnant quand on voit que ma
communauté youtube et à 75% composé de
mec
j'aimerais bien qu'on équilibre
d'ailleurs les trois premiers films
préférés des 65 mille cinq cent trente
cinq personnes sont dans l'ordre
harry potter avatar et deadpool ces
trois films valent 7 % des réponses que
j'ai eus donc à peu près quatre mille
cinq cents personnes
ensuite dans le top 10 nous avons en 4e
fight club en 5e star wars
après inception batman la ligne verte
pulp fiction et enfin titanic ses sept
films là donc dans mon classement de 4 à
10 représentent que 10 % des réponses
donc 6500 réponse après pour tout le
reste y avait pas de tendances majeures
mais ça veut dire que si vous rencontrez
quelqu'un et que vous lui demandez quel
est son film préféré il ya quand même 17
% de chances que ce soit l'un de ses dix
films c'est pas mal mais dans les autres
questions on a des statistiques encore
plus hallucinant toutes les autres
questions que j'ai posées à la suite
avait ce point commun qu'il fallait
répondre sans réfléchir je vous ai donc
demandé en question numéro 2 de me citer
le nom d'un super héros en année d'hôtes
marrante j'ai trois personnes qui m'ont
répondu 20h37 que trois personnes me
fasse le même réponse je loue ça c'était
étrange je sens une conspiration alors
là c'était beaucoup plus tranché que
pour les films spontanément quand je
vous ai demandé un super-héros 35%
d'entre vous m'ont répondu batman 35%
sur 65 mille cinq cent trente cinq
personnes c'est énorme
30% m'ont répondu superman je
l'attendais pas aussi haut dans le
classement et ensuite
pour cent des poules et 10% spider man
ils sont troisièmes à égalité mais
vraiment égalité à quelques vingtaine de
personnes près et 15% m'ont donné
d'autres nombre supérieur et ça c'est
très intéressant par exemple si vous
voulez faire un tour de mentalisme à
quelqu'un à tour un petit peu bleus font
vous pouvez préparer quelque chose en
sachant qu'il ya 85 % de chances qu'on
vous répondent batman superman spider
man ou deadpool la troisième question
c'est que vous deviez me donner un
nombre ou un chiffre entre 0 et 100
celle ci je vous le dis franchement pour
moi je pensais que c'était une question
mortes et un petit peu inutile mais il
s'est révélé certaines choses certains
d'entre vous ont voulu me faire marrer
en mettant des moins un ou dépit des
3,14 des trois points 14 15 et une
insulte au passage on sait pas pourquoi
mais alors là tenez vous bien
vingt mille d'entre vous ont répondu un
chiffre entre 0 et 9 presque dix mille
9500 et quelques ont répondu 42e alors
là je sais pas trop comment réagir c'est
à dire que 40 de ces quelque chose moi
quand je demande un chiffre qui est
souvent revenu sur tous les âges toutes
les catégories socio culturel tous les
genres mais vous et moi on sait que 40
de celles à la réponse réponse à la
grande question sur la vie sur l'univers
pourtant ceux qui m'ont répondu 42e moi
dans ma vie courante ne connaissent pas
forcément la référence du guide du
voyageur galactique et quand j'ai lu
pourquoi l'auteur avait choisi 42 à
l'époque il dit qu'il y avait rien de
spécial derrière que c'était le nombre
qui lui paraissait le plus aléatoire
possible le plus neutre possible et je
me demande si notre cerveau est pas
configuré pour dire 42 quand ils
cherchent un monde complètement
aléatoire bon ça a pas grande valeur
scientifique en ce que je vous dis là
c'est juste mon interprétation et mon
ressenti et d'une manière générale les
nombres ensuite avait à peu près la même
statistique de sortie sauf 1,82 qui n'a
été dit que 3 x 82 étaient mal aimés ou
j'en sais rien mais c'était étonnant
j'aurais même été agréablement surpris
qu en un qui soit pas cité du tout sûr
65000 réponse aurait été intéressant il
y avait que 100 réponses possibles alors
que la prochaine question il ya beaucoup
moins de réponses possibles puisque je
vous demandais de donner spontanément
une des notes dorées mi fa sol la si là
encore il ya des choses marrantes par
exemple il ya huit d'entre vous qui
m'ont répondu come as you are
ce qui voudrait dire que tous ceux qui
n'ont pas compris la question sont des
fans de come as you are de nirvana j'en
sais rien bref sinon quasiment 86 % des
réponses 85,9 % des réponses ont englobé
les deux notes suivantes le dos et le
dos aux 44 % des réponses et la presse
que 42% des réponses et les autres sont
à peu près équilibré donc et encore si
on devait faire un forçage psychologique
à quelqu'un sur une note de mise
on pourrait avoir 85 % de chances
d'aller vers le dos et le là ce qui
signifie que si on rajoute un petit peu
de forçage quelconque par les mots par
l'hypnose conversationnelle par autre
chose
on devrait atteindre 1 99 % assez facile
mais on arrive à la question suivante de
donnez moi une capitale sans réfléchir
alors là écrasant il ya eu 26 réponse
différente de 26 villes différentes ont
été traitées 25 villes ne représentent
que 7% des réponses j'aurais peut être
pour vous compreniez à quel point c'est
énorme sur les vingt-six villes
différentes mans et donnait 25 débit ne
représentent que 7% des réponses ce qui
veut dire que de 93 % des réponses
étaient une seule et même ville je vous
le donne en mille et mille c'était paris
spontanément apparemment on donne la
capitale du pays auquel on habite c'est
ce qui nous vient le premier à l'esprit
et de là je vous ai demandé de me dire
le nom d'un monument célèbre sans
réfléchir alors je pense qu'il ya un
vrai biais cognitifs entre la réponse
paris précédente et le monument qui suit
derrière ça ce serait dur à analyser
faudrait refaire le test sans qu'ils
aient d'autres questions avant parce que
les questions peuvent s'influencer
entrée à lille peut y avoir comme c'est
un chemin de pensée qui est en train de
se créer néanmoins 47 % des réponses
étaient la tour eiffel 23% pour la
statue de la liberté et 22% pour la tour
de pise la tour de pise je l'avais pas
vu venir je pensais que l'arc de
triomphe serait un peu en avant ou le
louvre ou les pyramides d'egypte mais
non la tour de pise en troisième et si
vous avez fait le compte pendant que je
parlais vous rendez compte que toutes
les autres réponses ne représentait que
8 % des réponses cette petite expérience
nous aura bien montrer qu'on a des
schémas de réflexion et penser à peu
près identique en tous cas pas si varié
qu'on le pense parce que si je prends
l'exemple des monuments célèbres en été
car 11 réponse différente aux réponses
sur 60 5535 personnes s'est pas beaucoup
et on a bien un mode de réponse
spontanée un peu prévisibles ces
réponses là toutes ces statistiques vous
allez pouvoir faire ce que vous voulez
ça peut vous servir comme je vous disais
à améliorer des effets le mentalisme a
peut-être mieux comprendre à quel point
peut influencer quelqu'un en coupant sa
réflexion préalable ou tout simplement
pour votre culture personnelle alors
j'ai essayé aussi de dégager des
peut-être des bien évident entre l'âge
entre les suites des réponses entre si
quelqu'un aime bien paris est ce que il
a tendance à aimer le même film par
exemple
bon il y avait rien de très intéressant
en dégager mais ça prenait quand même
dit on à faire dans la vidéo que j'ai
publié juste avant celle ci je vous
donnais une petite énigme vous
permettant de tirer un indice pour un
concours qui aura lieu bien peu concours
que j'annonçais dans cette vidéo sachez
que dans cette vidéo également se cache
quelque chose qui vous donnera encore
une fois un indice une avance
vous recommande de ne pas mettre ce que
vous trouvez dans les commentaires parce
que le jour où l'énigme va sortir pour
gagner ce que vous savez si vous avez
décoder les énigmes près là vous aurez
de l'avant ce jeu se passe sur que vous
ayez envie de donner de l'avancé aux
autres c'est vous qui voyez après moi je
ne modère pas les commentaires vous
faites ce que vous voulez si vous êtes
encore là ce stade de la vidéo n'oubliez
pas de laisser un pouce en l'air pour me
dire vous les regarder en entier que
vous avez aimé et bien sûr n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner avant de partir en
dévoue très bientôt peut-être ce
week-end activer la cloche ce que vous
voulez ciao